like this is a big question coming out
but have aliens or uaps or any
extraterrestrial
interdimensional beings reached out to
you as someone who's a spokesperson have
you had any interaction have you seen a
ship have you had any kind of personal
experience and if you don't want to
answer I understand no so I'm I'm a
total open book like I have to be you
know I feel duty if if if if I withhold
anything you know i' I'd be pillared for
it the thing is is that I I'm sad to
report to you that I'm always the guy
with my back turned see something cool
they scream I'm inside getting my night
vision so everybody can see the stars
better there's some UFO so I was always
that guy for like ever forever man I
never saw [__] you know and I kind of
liked it that way I was like that's
pretty cool because no one's going to
believe me if I see
something luckily
right luckily uh not that long ago I had
a very much more credible than me friend
his name is Dave Foley he's a comic
right um from Kids in the Hall and he
was visiting me and he started taking
the piss at me being like ah come see
the UFO expert and don't see a UFO
that's pretty good you know he's [__]
with me not 45 seconds later I say Dave
look the [__] up and that was the first
time in my life I can say that I ever
saw a craft of Unknown Origin that was
capable of doing something unlike what I
know is possible with our known
understanding of physics when you say
it's not possible by our aircraft and
like what what we really mean is
straight up defying the laws of physics
uh it's using a uh it's applying itself
in a world of physics that we don't we
must not understand right is it this the
science hasn't caught up with the
technology yet yeah so Material Science
is our number one throttle on any r
verse engineering attempts of these
materials are craft and I can explain
that really deeply or simply if you want
but that's the number one thing is our
material science evolution from my
understanding has not caught up to being
able to duplicate or replicate the
actual uh physical materials enough to
even begin to start and I I would assume
that it it's all operating in and buy
laws that don't even apply to to our our
physical science well let's talk about
that for a second cuz it's if I can get
it anybody can get it and the thing is
I've tried to understand it and and what
I'm what we're talking about is a UFO
will appear and disappear okay great so
we have stealth technology that can make
that appear to be the case for us you
know on radar or optically we have
pretty good technology we can cloak
machines we're getting much better at it
but but additionally there's other
signatures they say like let's just say
thermal like where you can mask that but
also UFOs can seem and this is the
biggest one they can appear to have zero
inertial effect so if I if I'm going 100
miles hour but then jolt 2,000 mph my
body becomes jelly on the back
wall these craft seem to be able to move
at 90° turns at documented about 12,000
mph so not even the machine itself
should be able to handle that that kind
of turn so obviously there's no inertial
effect so what do we know that can cause
that type of thing well sure time travel
temporal but also we don't understand
gravity if there's a way to produce
gravity like Bob Lazar said cuz right
now the only thing produces gravity is
is mass is matter right but if we could
generate gravity you could theoretically
create a gravitational field that is
inert like you you it doesn't matter
where you're moving moving through time
and space you're always in a
gravitational field that is right for
you that's why they think some of these
craft can move they call transm medium
from space through air without a sonic
boom they can move at speeds and into
the sea without disturbance without
slowing down that's transm medium so the
idea of how do they do that with physics
some people say well the craft skin you
know it's like hydrophobic when you go
in just slips in but really what we're
seeing is we're seeing objects that
appear to move in ways that our physics
understands we just can't replicate
gravitational fields so they must have
some way of doing it if that's the way
they're doing it and that's what Bob
laar is saying they had that thing where
you couldn't touch it and it kept
pushing you back that's the idea behind
what that is yeah the the propulsion
system so if anybody doesn't know who
Bob Lazar is you know he's a guy that
claims that he reversed engineered or
tried to a UFO for the United States
military in 1989 he came forward through
George nap that's how you know about
Area 51 and flying saucers in general MH
Bob said he worked on an alien
spacecraft From Another
World it was a
saucer and the propulsion system the
power and propulsion was what he was
tasked on
examining and he said when you turn on
this gravity wave amplification
machine you couldn't bring your hands
close to it so that was an aspect of
what he experience there were other
weird things like bringing a candle up
towards it and it was like frozen
looking just stopped which he said made
no sense because electrons should be
sucked into that void they shouldn't
Escape that field so he doesn't even
know but basically yeah that's bobazar
that is the idea I don't know if it
works that way I'd love to know do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is sto's butt wipes for your
buttthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce for your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and steo
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude